I have one of the biggest honors
that I think any politician could have,
in that I was elected the mayor
of the place in which I was born
and brought up.
So that's Bristol in the UK.
Well, thank you.
(Applause)
And it's a big job.
From education to housing,
to budgets to trash collection
to protests to counterprotests,
cities are complicated organisms.
They can be tumultuous,
and they can be full of contradiction.
And as the mayor, I am the accountable
person within Bristol.
The buck stops with me.
And that sometimes is even for issues
over which I have very little
real control or power.
And that's fine.
That's life.
But I have another constituency
to whom I'm accountable,
and that's one that is within my city,
but reaches beyond my city boundaries.
And that's the planet
and the 7.9 billion other people
who depend on it for their survival.
We've got ourselves into a situation
where it would take 1.7 Earths
for our current way of living
to be sustainable.
So something's got to give.
And I think we all know
we ain't getting any more Earths, right?
So inevitably it's us who need to change.
And as we look around and listen in
on the international negotiations,
as we look at national inaction too often,
there'll be many people wondering
how we're going to take this challenge on.
And even if we're going to be successful.
And I understand it,
so many people around the world
will be losing hope.
But my message today is there is hope,
and it’s hiding in plain sight.
And I believe there's huge
hope in our cities.
So consider these four numbers.
Three,
55,
75,
80.
Cities occupy less than three percent
of the Earth's land surface.
So we have a small geographical footprint.
In fact, if you put all the cities
of the world together,
you could fit them into India.
And yet cities are home to over half,
55 percent, of the world's population.
And we anticipate
that will grow to two thirds
by the middle of this century.
Cities are responsible for around
75 percent of CO2 emissions.
And we're also prodigious emitters
of nitrogen dioxide and methane.
And cities consume 80 percent
of the world's energy.
But think about this.
That it’s the characteristics of cities --
their reach, their size, their density,
close proximity of the leadership
to the people, their adaptability
and their capacity for reinvention --
that mean that we can actually
plan to manage those numbers.
That means through our cities,
we can actually plan to do more,
for more people, with less.
And it's why I say cities
are one of the most effective tools
we have at our disposal
for leveraging efficiency
into our relationships with land,
energy and waste.
Through our cities,
we can increase the efficiency
of more human lives more quickly
than through any other form
of human organization.
So we can, for example,
house and employ more people on less land,
minimizing the pressure on urban sprawl
which competes then for land, for nature,
while minimizing the distances
people have to travel
to meet their basic needs.
Through cities, we can have people
sharing energy by sharing buildings
and through smart innovations
like heat networks.
The density in our cities
makes public transport more accessible
and more cost-effective.
And through our cities, we can transform
our relationship with energy.
We need energy security right now.
But cities offer markets of such scale
that they make investing in renewables
more financially attractive.
And think about
the opportunities with waste.
We can leverage efficiency
into the collection
and processing of waste
while introducing the principles
of the circular economy at scale
so that resources are recycled,
goods are reused
and unavoidable waste
is processed for energy,
for example, food waste for fertilizer.
Now just think about the global potential
of a worldwide network of cities
scaling up these kinds of efficiencies
for over half and coming on two thirds
of the world's population.
And here is the hope
I mentioned at the beginning.
You don't have to just imagine that.
From Freetown to Los Angeles,
from Kampala to London,
and in many, many cities in between,
mayors, city leaders
are stepping up and taking action
to meet the challenge of the moment.
So take Malmö, a city
of just under 350,000 people.
They’ve developed a heat network
that is fed by heat
generated by processed waste.
They intend to be 100 percent
powered by renewable
or recycled heat by 2030.
Oslo is a city that's subsidizing
electric vehicles and charging points.
They have introduced a circular
waste management system.
They've purchased a biogas plant,
and nearly 50 percent
of all their food waste is recycled.
(Applause)
Singapore is one of the densest
cities in the world,
but they are a model of green planning.
In recent years, they've introduced
huge freshwater reserves
and urban gardens
that act as the lungs of the city.
And I have a huge amount
of admiration for Bogota as well,
one of the densest cities
in Latin America.
They've introduced
the bus rapid transit system.
They're making walking
and cycling more accessible,
and today, have one of the largest fleets
of electric buses in Latin America.
And while I have the stage,
let me show off a little bit
about my own city, Bristol,
home to 465,901 people,
one of whom is here today.
We have a fantastic reputation
for being one of the greenest
cities in Europe.
In Bristol, we have a housing crisis.
We must build homes.
But we're very conscious of the fact
that the kind of homes we build
and where we build them
will be one of the biggest determinants
of the price the planet pays
for our growth.
So we're focused on delivering
net-zero homes at higher density
on old industrial land
in the middle of the city.
This allows us to relieve
the pressure for urban sprawl.
It allows us to design in active travel
and design out car dependency.
We're even taking action
on the climate consequences
of the humble toilet.
Across our public housing stock,
we are replacing bathrooms
and we're taking the opportunity
to replace the fittings
with more water-efficient alternatives,
more water-efficient showers,
sinks and taps,
and more water-efficient toilets.
So not all climate change action
is full of glamour, is it?
But we mayors are not just focused
on what happens inside
our city boundaries.
You'll find mayors all over the world
are leading beyond their authority.
They're coming together
in international networks
to set hard target for decarbonization
to which they hold themselves
mutually accountable.
You'll find hundreds
of these city solidarity networks
live in the world right now.
The Global Covenant of Mayors
for Climate and Energy
is a network of around 12,000 cities.
They've made a collective
commitment to take action
to ensure that 2030 emissions
are nearly two gigatons lower
than they would otherwise be
if we carried on as we are.
And as mayors,
we're also stepping up to influence
international organizations
and the global policy
that can support us to take action.
The C40 is a network of nearly 100 mayors
representing the world's
biggest global cities.
City diplomacy is central to their work.
Members attend national
and international negotiations
with the aim of influencing decision
making and global commitments.
And let me just say,
what you get with mayors is a commitment
to ensure that these global commitments
are turned from words into actions.
Our proximity to our residents
means that we are immediately accountable
for delivering change
that people can see and experience.
But herein we bump into another challenge.
We will not get the worldwide network
of efficient cities that we need
without major investment.
We will not get a worldwide network
of decarbonized cities
just because we need it,
we want it
or because we make
flowery declarations about it.
We will only get them
when we plan it and then pay for it.
In the end, city leaders around the world
struggle to get access
to the kind of finance they need
to unlock their city's full potential.
And yet, here, too,
we're not waiting around.
In the UK, I'm part of something called
the UK Cities Climate
Investment Commission.
It's our aim to put
the UK's biggest cities in touch
with the finance they need
for that potential to be released.
We've identified 206 billion pound's worth
of decarbonization opportunities
across the UK,
retrofitting, renewables,
transition of fleet to electric.
And we are making sure
that public and private investors
are aware of these opportunities
across the UK.
So here's the thing.
Mayors, city leaders,
we haven't got time for abstract debates
or merely flowery declarations.
Our populations want change today.
They want change yesterday.
The climate crisis we're in
demands leadership.
And mayors I meet around the world
are stepping up into that space
to meet the moment.
We want and need national governments
and international organizations
to work with us, to back us,
to support us.
But we cannot wait for them.
The world's top scientists tell us
we've got ten years
to turn this thing around.
And because of a history of inaction,
underperformance,
turgidness in decision making,
that means that right now
we need to make some big bets
and we need to make
some big bets on interventions
that will deliver change
at scale and pace.
And I think our cities give us good odds.
So here's my call to action.
We need to work with the world's mayors
to develop a global plan for cities.
It's a plan that must decarbonize
and build efficiency into existing cities,
but to make sure that the future
processes of urbanization
maximize city efficiency.
And when I say global,
I do mean global.
It's a plan that must transcend
national boundaries.
It must be in the Global North,
and it must be in the Global South,
where 90 percent of future urbanization
is going to take place.
And it's a plan
that must have us move beyond
our narrow self-national interest.
We must come to see the world's cities
as international assets
rather than national possessions.
We must come to see
that investing in the increased efficiency
of the world's cities
is key to our future.
It's going to be key
to unlocking our potential.
And it's an investment
in our global common good.
When I was elected
mayor of Bristol in 2016,
I had a limited appreciation
of the global role of the city.
And by extension,
I had a limited appreciation
of the level of responsibility
that was therefore falling on my shoulders
as a newly-elected mayor
of a major UK city.
In the years since,
I've come to understand that cities,
the way they are planned,
the way they function,
the way they grow
and the way they innovate
will be key to whether we are
or are not successful
in taking on this challenge
to stem the tide of global climate change.
If we can unlock the full
potential of our cities,
we can minimize the price the planet pays
for hosting us in our growing numbers.
I think efficient cities could be one
of the most effective tools we have.
So I ask you to work with us
to build them.
Thank you.
(Applause)